ciao ragazzi buon 2021 ha ben tornati
alla prima puntata di cucina buttata di
questo nuovo anno è finito il blog ma
spero che vi sia piaciuto fatecelo
sapere qua sotto
io purtroppo sono un guglielmo del
passato quindi ho ancora un sacco di
sogni e non ho la più pallida idea di
come sia andata questa esperienza
sapevamo già che ci saremmo dovuti
prendere un pochino di tempo alla fine
del blog ma perché come ben sapete
questo è stato il terzo anno e abbiamo
capito una cosa da col tempo che alla
fine arrivavamo sempre della stati in
questo momento molto probabilmente siamo
ognuno a casa sua a fissare il soffitto
a chiedersi in che modo riuscirà a
riprendere le proprie forze
di una cosa siamo certi non sappiamo se
sia andato tutto bene non sappiamo se
sempre ci sa fare tutto quello che
volevamo fare ma siamo sicuri di esserci
sfondati come dei maiali ecco perché
prima ricetta di quest'anno è una sfida
riuscire a creare un piatto a zero
calorie una roba che mangi ma che non ha
simili minimamente mentre mangi cag e
cioè quindi è una giostra
simbolo di eni fumante a questa volta
non abbiamo una ricetta ma abbiamo
trovato una lista di cibi che hanno
praticamente un apporto calorico pari a
zero e quindi ci siamo detti ci
riuniremo probabilmente faremo anche una
pietanza con un apporto calorico pari a
zero per fare il piatto 0 kcal avremmo
bisogno di un cavolo fiorito 3 chili e
100 grammi un mazzo di asparagus se kcal
per gambo rocco siffredi 6 kcal per
pezzo harry dov'è il secondo da noi kcal
per 100 g cioè però firmate da 100
grammi di aglio inoltre è un ottimo ed
eccellente bruciagrassi sedano 2 kcal
per gambo consumi più calorie a
mangiarlo di galletti da lattuga 14 kcal
per 100 g fragole 3 kcal per pezzo
inoltre aiutano la digestione lamponi
una sola kcal per pezzo pieni di
vitamina c e allo stesso tempo aiutano
la fertilità girone con tre kcal affetta
un fa 24 kcal a grappolo ma permettono
di assimilare meno calorie rubare anche
queste mele 47 kcal per 100 g che l di
vitamina c vitamina c v da 7 kcal a
spicchio è infine spezie pari e mo nun
me le racconto per il dopo perché ancora
non so cosa usare cosa non usare via che
sia chiaro lo ripeto io non ho idea di
che cosa andremo a fare anche se mentre
presentavo i nostri alimenti nel già
venuta in mente una ricetta
io cercherò di creare una carbonara con
gli alimenti che abbiamo adesso come fai
non c'è pasta non c'è carne mater
carbonara andare avanti abbiamo bisogno
di continuare a fermare la prima cosa
che faremo oggi è il con leaf laureys il
riso al cavolo fiorito
prendiamo il cavolfiore abbiamo già
sciacquato aveva cercato ma questa è la
parte divisa che preferisce quella dove
certo il riso col cavolo col cavolo che
faccio il riso ecco da dove viene il
riso si sa in realtà c'è qualcuno che fa
così con la natura per il cavolo
federico ragazzi commenta tutti quanti
questo tuo capo è fiorito lavo hai dato
un effetto riso che non mi aspettavo
l'hai visto io spero di dare da anni un
effetto riso a chiunque ci ascolta con
un filo d'olio si dovrebbe fare
ma noi a qualche triste acqua non saremo
niente ragazzi è una ricetta dietetica
olio che esce dal rubinetto como e
ragazzi sto esagerando per controllare
se questo olio e trasparente è arrivato
a temperatura vi consiglio di prendere
un po di acqua e di buttarci sopra
vedere sis critica ancora butto dentro
il riso cinque minuti chiudiamo e
lasciamo andare a fuoco basso io direi
ragazzi non voglio fare pazzie mia forse
per aggiungere un po di olio ne risolva
ciliano dall'altra agata sapore lo so
dovremo andare a creare un effetto
pancetta che cosa ne pensate che sono
sicuramente bravissimi non voglio
utilizzarne troppi carriera pericolosi
il gambo non lo prendiamo tutto non
adesso una cosa importantissima io so
che molti domani mi criticheranno perché
diranno che nella carbonara non ci va
soffritto che può cipolle aglio ma io
metterò sia la cipolla e l'aglio e
cadenti eh sì stiamo veramente nutrendo
vorrei avere un pochino più di sapore fa
che già molto ricca così però apprezzo
molto il sapore della cipolla e non ti
ricordiamoci che la cipolla agli strati
ma non fa un cazzo agli strati come gli
orchi a tutti e due abbiamo gli strati
cipolla aglio le calorie the spicchio
qui stiamo un po esagerando ti prendo un
po d'olio poteri sempre rubinetto le
varie mazzata facciamo una saporita dai
che ci frega low pretty dell'anima
iscrivetevi a questo canale attivate la
campagna delle notifiche vi prego fatelo
dateci una mano ma soprattutto metteteci
un like se del piaciuto il blog ma se
vorreste che anche in questo 2021 tra 12
mesi quando c'e la risentiremo arrivi
una quarta stagione di questo nostro
format
fermo mettono il paraschizzi aggiungiamo
asparagi tenete il grasso non buttatelo
via vorrei evitare alla fine di
utilizzare altro olio quindi utilizzando
direttamente il grasso la verdura
nel frattempo andiamo subito a lavorare
alla crema di uova ma secondo me abbiamo
buffa useremo un fatto ed andiamo a
inserire ok abbiamo l'uva che diminuisce
l'assunzione delle calorie
c'è il rischio che si vada sotto zero è
il nostro obiettivo andare sotto zero
mettiamo i tuorli dentro che aveva detto
che avremmo utilizzati una kcal al
lampone
cerchiamo di utilizzare meno tuorli
degli album per favore a rete e macinato
costati al punto giusto e poi parmigiano
questo e cumino ragazzi come l'ha
sentita anche un po di colore mamma mia
mi è venuto rossissimo cappadocia legge
mangiare ciccio più velocemente
possibile
vuol dire il ciccio ma scrittura
[Applauso]
semplice ma ragazzi quale mamma mia
ragazzi e ha avuto un piccolo intoppo ai
partner conteniamo l'uovo e lo piazziamo
nella padella però così diventano
frittata ci andrò ad aggiungere dei
piccoli pezzetti di sedano mela cetriolo
che aiuteranno a non diventare una
frittata si sa che le proprietà del
sedano del centro insalata che aiuta a
renderlo più even siano è fondamentale
rocco mamma mia che c'entra non lo so
sto coso l'unica cosa che hanno
veramente in comune è il nulla che li
compone scusa luogo a un po di paprika
ragazzi da guarda che ho imparato tutto
infatti sto per dire la stessa cosa
lamela
[Risate]
fondamentale questa roba da poco un
colore ambiguo sembra proprio nuovo a
scassare un po di limone perchè fare
qualcosa si così se mister mangone
intravede che mi viene da dire
carbonara ma perché non è ancora messo
la pancetta
vi faccio vedere come mai trattato
questo piatto mettete il riso ragazzi la
pancetta ma sopra spolverata di pecorino
allegato al dvd in quello di libri pepe
venisse presentato un ristorante anche
vedere dove mi in chiaro la carbonara
calo ordinato ai fan che ne dici di
sollevarmi d'acquisto quando guglielmo
se ne esce con queste genialate sono
momenti di puro terrore prima della
faggio basta cazzate abbiamo scherzato
abbiamo riso in faccia messo un pochino
di cervello e intuito tema di aver
fallito proprio miseramente partendo
dall'aspetto posso dire che non è
disastroso all'avido finge di non sapere
che cosa sia perché quella salsa per me
è forse la cosa più la vista piace
ragazzi questo così direi uno sformatino
non a carbonara ecco non è insufficiente
potrebbe essere una leccornia in realtà
quindi sei e mezzo edito 76 e mezzo
colorato cioè tutto un verdone
chissà ho la sensazione che più andremo
avanti più la situazione peggiori odore
ma non sento il cavolfiore
ecco le prime magagne ma è stato solo il
cavolfiore io stranamente una
leggerissima nota di cavolfiore senza
arte né parte
basta sinceramente non cento la cipolla
6 meno 5 e mezzo insufficiente 6 meno
dai non voglio essere cattivo sapore
allora non ho mai mangiato niente di più
inutile di questo piatto sapone
altamente insufficiente eppure qualcosa
secondo me in ombra sgradevole e aria
piero speranzoso sapevo che non avrei
assaggiato chissà che piatto gli ho dato
fiducia mi ha tradito non so se ti
ricordi il pumpkins non ci siamo per
niente peggio vegetali hanno acquoso ma
avendo zero calorie se tutti inutili di
questo per sempre fuori
sì sì sì sì sì cioè non ti dà nutrimento
necessario a sopravvivere 5 c'è qualcuno
che magari potrebbe amare quest'anno
acqua o 5 nero quanto e mezzo
complessivamente da un piatto re5 meno
quattro e mezzo posso dire non
classificato purtroppo di deo dai 540
euro lo pagherei in un futuro dove non
esiste il cibo e voglio che sarebbe
l'unica forma per nutrire sempre non so
5 dracme cinque monete d'aria un
qualcosa che non ha più valore ma vi
sembra un piatto
altrimenti il cosiddetto baratterei più
fredda nel logo di non assaggiarlo lodo
era un rapinatore altrimenti quale
fratello però potrebbe vincere il premio
come ricetta più inutile di cucina
buttata nella storia proprio del format
ma se questo piatto non venisse nominato
sotto forma di carbonara giusto
giustissimo a 4 ea quello che pagherei
un paio di occhiali e che mi dice questo
a carbonara
ma le ragazze ribera ha messo angoscia
mai più comunque ragazzi siamo li ha
tirati di questo video dalla prossima
domenica arriveranno nuovi episodi di
cucina buttata speriamo che vi piacciano
fateci sapere questo cosa ti piacerebbe
vedere quest'anno in che modo vorreste
vedere evolvere il canale per il momento
il mio lavoro da guglielmo del passato è
finito lasciano spazio al bullismo del
presente d'ora in poi mi mando un bacio
grande come sempre invito a iscrivervi a
questo canale cerchiamo di crescere e
sappiate che se lo farete questo che
sarà un anno più fortunato cioè non che
ci voglia molto essere più fortunati
rispetto al 2020 attivate la campania
delle notifiche e soprattutto metteteci
un bel pollice in su per il visto che
nessuno sa più che abbia preso il
cetriolo e quindi dovrete sopperire in
qualche modo vi mando un bacio ci
vediamo giovedì alle 12 con un altro
video
ciao
[Risate]